hey what is up guys mkbhd here and today
we're going to be taking a look at and
reviewing
the human hand so there's a ridiculous
amount of different models and specs
available so pretty much everyone's
model will be different but this is the
one i have here it is the 9 inch in
space gray so it's pretty tall and
definitely lightweight and i'd say feel
in the hand is
pretty average you can get used to it
the opposable thumb design is definitely
great i don't know why other species
aren't doing this yet i really think it
should come standard you also get a pair
of them and this right one here
is broken it's actually no longer
functional i don't know what kind of
warranty i got with it but it was
definitely normal use and i guess maybe
the material choice or the way it was
constructed internally
not so hot so i have this third party
case on it the doctor doesn't run
recommend taking it off
but is he a real doctor i mean dr dre is
not a real doctor no i'm just kidding
but no i actually did break my hand uh
playing ultimate frisbee though at
practice two days ago not trying to bend
a phone like some people thought so
that's going to affect and change a
whole bunch of things not only in
production but like in the rest of my
life because you kind of need two hands
to do a bunch of stuff number one i'm
already pretty decent at texting with my
left hand now although i do appreciate
speech to text much more breaking a hand
really makes you realize how much of
this world is designed for two-handed
people or people who can use both hands
not just the little things but like you
know
writing notes in class i broke my
writing hand
driving a car
uh let me see uh tying my shoes i
haven't actually done that since i can't
tie knots operating or unboxing almost
anything handheld is really hard now uh
a mouse and keyboard kinda hard to do so
email if you've emailed me in the past
like day or so give me a chance i'll get
to it uh video editing
how am i gonna edit this video i don't
know
so i never really like to name upcoming
projects that i have coming up but
obviously this is going to delay my
iphone 6 review my iphone 6 plus review
and other videos that i've had upcoming
because now it's really hard to edit and
things like that take time of course i'd
still if i have a chance i'd rather be
the best video than the first video if i
can help it so looking at the bright
side breaking my hand has given me the
opportunity to finish up the behind the
scenes changes i was going to be making
anyway and to start to focus more on
quality quality of information and
quality of the videos that i put out so
the frequency will be a little bit less
in the next six to eight weeks as i
recover and maybe get surgery and fix my
hand but i just wanted to put out this
quick video saying thanks for your
patience uh and thanks for your kind
words i tweeted about it and plenty of
people have said get well soon so thanks
for your kind words and uh hopefully the
videos will be back on the normal track
when i'm on the other side of this also
if anyone has any tips for like
one-handed living for people who broke
their dominant hand definitely feel free
to leave them in a comment below
uh and if you want to keep up with the
more timely stuff that i'm sharing
because september's not even over we
haven't even seen the next nexus android
l a bunch of other phones that are
coming out so follow me on twitter uh
because i can still tweet with one hand
so that's still intact
so there you go just wanted to get that
out there thank you for watching and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace